[Musique]
bienvenue à tous paris saclay tv est de
retour nous voici sur le site du futur
digitec digitec ce sera le pôle
numérique de votre territoire
le projet a été dévoilé lors des digital
days nous reviendrons aussi sur smart
cities expédition ce programme a été
lancé il ya deux mois par le pea paris
saclay par nokia
c'est un programme d'innovation
collaborative l'objectif étant de
développer un réseau d'objets connectés
dédié à la mobilité sur paris saclay et
parmi les projets présentés il ya des
cars poule et ses voitures connectées
nous étions aussi présent à la cérémonie
des diplômes des masters pour la school
sciences sociales c'était la première
promotion des master sciences sociales
de l'université paris saclay rendez vous
était donné à sow des étudiants qui vont
bientôt pouvoir profiter d'un nouvel
espace de vie au nom poétique le jardin
à rechanter le grand public y aura accès
pour l'instant c'est un peu un chantier
mais on vous y emmène quand même
ce sera à la fin de cette émission et
bien sûr nous retrouvons notre agenda
c'est donc ici que s'installera digitec
digitec c'est le futur pôle numérique de
votre territoire ce projet qui se fera
autour des acteurs actuels de nano innov
a été dévoilé lors des digital days
l'occasion pour le liste de présenter
ses toutes dernières nouveautés
écoutez les précisions de philippe
bateau c'est le directeur du liszt
l'institut de ceatec
[Musique]
aujourd'hui 14 mars icpc vraiment
quelque chose d'important sur sur le
plateau de saclay un ensemble d'acteurs
de la recherche de soi de la recherche
amont jusqu'à la rue gerschell plus
appliquée dans le domaine du numérique
ont décidé de se réunir et de porter
ensemble un projet en commun
ce projet il s'appelle digitec
l'objectif c'est que le numérique sur le
plateau de saclay soit vraiment un axe
très fort un axe visible un axe
mobilisateur et fédérateur
c'est la raison pour laquelle le cea
list l'inria l'ird et system x
l'institut des télécoms et de pôles de
compétitivité
ce système est paris région ont décidé
ensemble de porter un projet en commun
ce projet en commun cet apport un projet
de rosemary scientifiques et techniques
et partage et qui a pour objectif
d'aider les entreprises nationales mais
aussi francilienne sans leur
développement technologies numériques
ce projet va s'incarner dans un bâtiment
qui s'appellera visite à klein
qui va réunir l'ensemble de ses acteurs
l'annoncé a été faite ce matin même a
fait entre vice président de la région
ile de france en charge de la recherche
elle a aussi inauguré ce matin même un
design center sur le site de nano innov
la digitec va se construire
gitex est donc à la fois un pôle
numérique d'activité à part est sacrée
mais c'est aussi un centre d'innovation
tirée par les usagers par le design ce
sont deux axes importants
yvon personnalisés ils vont caractériser
de projets de soleil
aujourd'hui je passe deux événements
importants
le premier porté par le cea list ces
deux textes et du lycée jeter des deux
listes c'est quoi ce sont toutes des
démonstrateurs technologiques cotées
capacités technologiques de l'institut
de recherche du cea
ils sont mis en visibilité sur mis en
avant deuxième événement
la journée futura de systèmes ips est
l'événement annuel de l'irt et systèmes
ips qui vise à mettre en avant les
différents travaux collaboratifs kouyaté
a permis de développer
c'est ainsi qu'aujourd'hui mais d'un
millier de personnes notamment et
principalement industrielle sont
présentes aujourd'hui pour célébrer ce
lancement du projet distinct revenons
maintenant sur le smart cities
expédition souvenez vous il y a deux
mois ce programme d'innovation
collaborative a été lancée par le pea
paris saclay et par nokia
l'objectif était de développer un réseau
d'obligés connecter sur votre territoire
des objets dédiés à la mobilité
nos étudiants ont planché découvrez des
cars poule un projet signé hussein
chabane
[Musique]
c'est notre projet c'est et carrefour
ça veut dire non pour le covoiturage
l'idée du projet c'est faire une
connexion entre deux voitures
de façon à avoir une caméra installée
sur une des deux voitures qui détecte la
plaque d'immatriculation de l'autre
voiture et on voit un message
personnalisé à la voiture destinataire
j'avais cette idée à cause d'un incident
qui m'est arrivé une fois j'étais en
train de conduire et j'avais les
écouteurs dans les oreilles et j'avais
les fermer les fenêtres fermées je sais
que c'est interdit la en france mais au
niveau 7 c'est pas interdit jusqu'au
moment
alors j'ai regardé le rétroviseur et
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qui me fait le
droit de l'arrière elle était vraiment
fâché après j'ai constaté qu'il était en
train de me clocks on est tout le temps
et moi j'ai comme j'avais les écouteurs
dans les oreilles j'ai pas entendu alors
j'étais quand dans une situation d' un
malentendant je me suis dit pourquoi il
n'y avait pas un moyen pour qu'il puisse
me contacter directement
ah si j'ai pas fait attention
cette idée sera très utile pour les
personnes malentendantes
parce que par exemple on a fait
recherché n'a trouvé que dans 60 pays
c'est interdit aux malentendants de deux
conduisent le projet c'était dans le
contexte du hac at on lancé par nokia
aux poteaux 204 sas a fait part du de
nantis les études en masse à m dos et il
s'était en fait le projet de fin de
l'année pour valider le master nous
devons présenter ce projet et j'avais la
chance d'être accepté de
travailler sur ce projet et ça s'est
bien passé nous nous envisageons d'avoir
un financier par exemple les
fabricateurs de des voitures comme
renault qui vont intégrer ce système
dans la fabrication des nouvelles
voitures à pour qu'elle soit utilisée
sur le terrain
et maintenant un grand bravo à tous les
diplômés des masters université paris
saclay pour la school sciences sociales
la première cérémonie de remise de
diplômes a eu lieu fin mars
aso paris saclay tv ne pouvait pas
manquer cet événement
regardez
[Musique]
bien ce matin et nous étions tous très
contents d'être rassemblés aso donc pour
la cérémonie de remise des diplômes de
master de l'université paris saclay
prenez school sciences sociales cette
school a souhaité se réunir d'abord pour
pour célébrer ces premiers diplômés donc
c'est il s'agit de la première promotion
des masters de l'université paris saclay
c'est un travail de longue haleine
puisque on l'a préparé il ya maintenant
plus de quatre ans donc c'était avant
tout donc un travail collaboratif entre
les équipes de recherche travaillant
dans le domaine des sciences sociales
sur à l'université paris sat et les
équipes ayant décidé donc de mettre la
force de leur laboratoire pour la
création de nouvelles structures de
formation de master donc pour la school
sciences sociales dans les domaines de
la sociologie des sciences sociales de
l'économie mais aussi donc de la banque
de la finance
l'université paris saclay donc au niveau
de la de la formation c'est une
expérience qui est unique en france
puisque nous avons été accrédités pour
49 ans sur ma star d'autres connus se
saisissent aussi de cette opportunité de
faire travailler les communautés
scientifiques ensemble autour des objets
de formation par la recherche que ce
soit le master ou doctorat donc pour
l'université paris saclay donc 100% gris
doctorants sont rassemblés donc sous la
bannière paris saclay au fur et à mesure
des années le nombre de mentions
augmente nous avons commencé à 44
mentions oussama 46 mentions donc cette
année ce qui regroupe à peu près neuf
mille cinq cents étudiants
donc il y avait aujourd'hui près de 200
deux sont diplômés présents avec leurs
familles beaucoup de gens en tout cas
donc
pour représenter donc l'équipe
enseignante aussi des personnels support
donc les sécrétariat pédagogique les
services de scolarité et c'est aussi ça
donc que l'université paris saclay c'est
cette mise en réseau des différentes
catégories de personnel donc qu'on a
souhaité rassembler aujourd'hui autour
autour des cérémonies
[Musique]
pour moi remarqué votre territoire se
transforme découvrez ce nouvel espace de
vie au nom très poétique le jardin
argenté il accueillera les étudiants
mais aussi le grand public pour
l'instant c'est un peu le chantier mais
on vous y emmène quand même
[Musique]
le jardin argenté est un lieu de
conception partagée à l'image du
patrimoine du plateau de saclay on a
essayé d'installer une vraie réflexion
sur la valeur de l'existant et du
patrimoine végétal existant pour en
faire un vrai jardin de quartier un lieu
de convivialité qui rassemble un certain
nombre d'écoles et qui vient relier la
zone suite de la lisière sud à travers
le carré des sciences l'école centrale
vers le dec
grâce à un système un élément un ouvrage
important du jardin qui est une
passerelle qui est-ce qui ont une allure
très fine et légère qui vient
s'installer sur ce socle de jardin pour
venir rejoindre la partie du thé
s'ouvrir sur l'unité
ce jardin est un lieu confortable de
convivialité avec une forte générosité
de plantation il réceptionne en partie
les eaux pluviales de l'école centrale
d'où une topographie assez marquée dans
lequel on vient accueillir aussi un
certain nombre d'éléments de mobilier
pour
donner des espaces des lieux de vie qui
ponctuent la dimension du jardin et qui
en fera un lieu de visite
[Musique]
le projet du jardin en contre et se
terminera donc fin juillet pour aussi
permettre une ouverture au public en
correspondance avec l'ouverture d'écoles
centrale prévue en septembre 2017
[Musique]
avant de nous quitter notre agenda bien
sûr tous les grands rendez vous à ne pas
manquer dans les jours qui viennent et
on commence avec le comité de suivi de
chantier du quartier de moulon ce sera
le 24 avril la finale 2 mt 182
l'université de paris saclay rendez vous
est pris le 27 avril
ce concours permet aux doctorants de
présenter leurs sujets de recherche en
français et en termes simples chaque
candidat à trois minutes seulement pour
présenter son projet un exposé clair
avec une seule diapositives à vous de
jouer la seconde édition de paris saclay
connexion ce sera le 27 juin l'occasion
de retrouver le paris saclay invest
l'événement dédié à la rencontre entre
start up et investisseurs et enfin du 8
au 10 juin
montez à bord du proto bus au futur en
seine c'est à la halle de la villette
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on reste
en forme sur tv fil 78 mais d'ici là
restez connectés sur notre site eps.fr
[Musique]